Master Chief loves football and the most
confused face ever it's a special
football episode of IMG North American
football gives you everything a guy
could want kicks to the face kicks to
the nuts and heads up your butt you get
to pick you can raise your baby as a
geek asaurus or as a jock but if you
want to be really direct just make it a
football of course football can be geeky
even though it's one of the manliest
sports in the world especially when you
do this next to this gap which at least
is a better accident than the light on
this girl's knee which looks like um
here's a lion not a detroit lion but an
upside-down mouse awesome costumes are
awesome but when your team loses you're
sad but still in a funny costume but how
about the worst team names ever there's
a high school called the water smeet
Nimrods we've got the Chattanooga
Central purple pounders Rhode Island
School of Design nads and a tiny High
School in Idaho actually called the
Butte pirates gift break
hey-yay-yay-yay Oh Aaron Rodgers is the
quarterback for the Packers but what's
his secret Oh
mascots are the best here we've got the
mascots for the Ravens Broncos
Buccaneers Jaguars and marijuana and the
only helmet more stupider than the Miami
Dolphins is this the Chargers have the
best haircuts and what could make Kobe
so excited Oh
even though the Pittsburgh Steelers have
the prettiest fans as well as the
biggest female fan base
jinda fries created these awesome dead
logos we've got the Buffalo Bills
bleeding a Cincinnati Bengals rug the
Denver Broncos heads and the Patriots
cheating oh and look some tasty Miami
Dolphin sushi but now it's time for
signs we're gonna crack your nuts the
Amherst QB is a virgin it burns when
Sparky pees and chase Daniels eats
boogers amazing catches are super cool
but no catch can compare to this
connection uploaded to facebook.com
slash Vsauce gaming by Eric I leave you
today with Eli Manning looking set be
sure to like us on Facebook and for a
double dose of fun go check out wacky
gamers know your street fighter every
week this month they'll have a new
episode on their channel it's street
fighter it's a puppet show I mean no duh
click here to watch it subscribe to them
for all their new stuff and as always
thanks for watching
you